[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: Fantastic.
All right, so here we are
on this gorgeous day James.
I hope you appreciate the weather.
JAMES LEONARD: I do.
PROFESSOR: And so let's
just start by you just
introducing yourself, a little
bit about your background,
and how you came to be here today.
JAMES LEONARD: My name is James Leonard.
And I am an artist.
And I live and work
in Brooklyn, New York,
but I'm back up here in the greater
Boston area with my current art work,
the Tent of Casually
Observed Phenologies.
Which is a, for lack
of a perfect term, it's
what I think people would call
a performance installation.
And this is a piece that was begun
back in February of this year, 2015.
When I was an artist in
residence at the Boston
Center for the Arts for
four months, as part
of their program of trying
to encourage and foster
the emergence of new artworks that
are socially engaged artworks.
PROFESSOR: My original inspiration
for this whole prediction,
prediction x course, now was
so that the public would really
understand what's behind
climate change simulations,
and that they would take seriously
the work that's being done.
And that they would think about
their future much more reflectively.
And that they wouldn't kind of
dismiss these predictions as uncertain
when they hear the word uncertainty.
And then what resonated so much with
me about your work and your project
is that you are also, I think,
trying to get the public
to think more about the future and
divination traditions and climate
change.
And I'm just curious if you can
tell us again a little bit more
about how the creation of the
tent and the research that you
did for this project relates
to the climate change issue.
JAMES LEONARD: The research for me has
really been a process of discovery.
Like, and I'm coming at this very
much as an artist and a humanist.
As opposed to a scientist or
an engineer, and saying aha,
I have a clear path.
And I may be actually giving
scientists, like putting them
too much on the, I
don't know, on the peg,
saying that you guys must know
what you're after when you start.
Because maybe you guys
begin with questions too.
Maybe that's it's
called research overall.
And for me, the first
question that, as well as
working on another
piece of media that was,
or another performance
piece where I was shaving
a boat away into a sea of shavings.
And this was in part a response to the
Arctic melt of 2012, which was one of,
it's the largest on record
that we've ever experienced.
And trying to relate to my own sort of
visceral emotions about that sense of--
the impermanence that that showed.
The massive scale of change.
And it came to me sort of as a
dreamlike image, this guy shaving
a boat out from underneath himself.
And so while I was
working on that, I was
realizing that I was working
a lot in my relationship
to the past and the present.
And somewhere along the way I
was thinking about the future.
And I think it started as a very
cynical and naive moment, where I said,
well if we're not going to
listen to climate scientists
we might as well be
listening to fortune tellers.
And at that point I had a very,
very different relationship
to divination than I do now.
Fast forward a couple
of years, and I've spent
a lot of time actually
working with diviners
of a number of different traditions.
Doing artworks about impermanence.
Doing artworks about my relationship
to try to understand divination.
And this side journey has
taken me into territory
where I'm now rethinking a lot
of my own original assumptions
about divination as something that--
I know I held what feels to me sometimes
in vernacular conversation with friends
and colleagues, seems to
be sort of a stereotype of,
well divination is protoscience.
It's science that isn't quite right yet.
And when you actually get
computers to tell you the answer
and run simulations for you,
you don't need it anymore.
Or when you have an accurate scientific
theory, you don't need it anymore.
And instead I've started seeing
it as a cultural practice.
Having now experienced
it both as a diviner.
I'm giving readings inside of
the tent about climate change.
And experiencing numerous readings
myself, receiving readings.
PROFESSOR: And that was part
of your research process--
JAMES LEONARD: That was
part of my research process.
Very much to try out.
Starting with the store
front fortune tellers,
and then going into more traditional
religious and cultural spaces
that took a long time to get into.
They're fairly closed communities.
A reading is made up of several
things, several components.
There's a diviner in
the querent, which is
the person who does the reading and
the person who asked the question.
And the reading itself begins
usually with a question or a concern,
something that has been brought.
And then there is
often a tool in between
that will be your method of divination.
Sometimes that's an internal method
in some cases like the people
who are members of the spiritualist
church will conduct seances.
And so their method of divination
is happening from visions and things
happening within their head.
PROFESSOR: Yeah we talk about
that a lot in the course.
About all the different kinds
of processes that people use.
And that some people use
random processes in nature.
Some people take the more
human spiritual approach.
And some people use some kind of
official randomizing influence,
like a tarot deck--
JAMES LEONARD: Like a tarot deck
PROFESSOR: or stones.
JAMES LEONARD: Or the I Ching Like
flipping quarters to do the I Ching
or casting the yarrow sticks.
PROFESSOR: So did you try all of those?
JAMES LEONARD: I haven't
tried all of them.
And there's several hundred existing
different methods of divination.
Some of which have been sort of lost to
history, but there are echoes of them.
There's Lore of them.
And I've found that that's sort of
a side interest that I've developed.
Is just sort of the flavor.
There's something about it that--
Very quickly as I was
just even exploring,
let's say, the Wikipedia entry
on all the methods of divination.
It's so long and half the
time it reads like something
from the 1960s conceptual
performance art.
That for me really moved me.
Like divination by dripping wax.
Divination by the tracks of beetles.
Divination by laughter.
But the thing that all of these
divinatory experiences that I've had,
when they function well
have had in common,
is that they create a space
that does a couple of things.
It creates a space that opens
up the mind for decision making.
It's not a substitute for freewill.
That's one of the first mistakes
that I think a lot of modern people
who are unexperienced in
divination come to it with.
PROFESSOR: You mean that it's not
a way to see a preordained future.
JAMES LEONARD: It's also not a
way to get a yes or no answer.
PROFESSOR: Right, and you know what I
have experienced by being in your tent
and talking with you,
is that there really
is this aspect of getting people
to think about their alternatives,
and about possible futures, and about
what they know about their own future.
And you were telling me earlier
that part of the role of the diviner
is to get the querent to really talk
and think openly, and to be in a space
where they can really kind
of have this experience where
they're focused on their own future.
And where they sort of can see their
world around them, but not really.
And I think that the space that you
made definitely accomplishes that.
JAMES LEONARD: And this leads us to
what the other main function that I've
seen in any of the successful
divinatory experiences that I've had is.
Which is, we're all taking
in so much information.
By the time you're 35, 40, 50 years old,
you have decades of life experience.
If you're an active
participant in the information
age, and you've read hundreds
of thousands of words.
You've experienced maybe
hundreds of academic theses
and takes on something, if
you're an expert in your field.
And how do you put all
those thoughts in order.
But what ends up happening, and I
believe we've used this term before,
that divination can function almost like
as a comb for all of those thoughts.
All that information
that you've taken in.
It's a way to sort of, if you
think about the way a comb can
move through hair, and lay it
into line and give it shape.
It's a way to take these hundreds
of thousands of different ideas
and start finding the
natural shape within it.
PROFESSOR: You know, there's a
story that David Carrasco who
is an expert on Mesoamerican
cultures told us.
I don't know whether we had
heard this story already
when I met you the first time.
But he talks about the gods
being annoyed with the humans.
That the humans on Earth
were learning too much
about the future and about the
world, and that they took a sort of,
a philosophical mirror.
And that they breathed on the
mirror to kind of fog up the view
that the humans have.
But that nature, around
the humans, still
has all these hints about the
future and what's going on.
And that a lot of the divinatory
practices in Mesoamerica
have a lot to do with nature
and natural phenomena.
And the idea is that they're
trying to see past this fog.
And it's the same kind of
thing you're talking about.
About the periphery about.
That there's information there
that people just don't normally
access in their everyday lives.
And they're sort of trying to find
a way to access that information.
And you know you might think
that I, as a scientist, you know,
wouldn't want to think
about the world that way.
But I think that there are
a lot of different ways
to think about the world.
And what you've taught me,
really in talking to you,
is that just like you
said, you know that you--
We were talking about
climate change a minute ago,
and you said, you know that you
thought, well we might as well just
listen to fortune tellers.
And when I started
working on this course.
I think that I was probably pretty
biased against this kind of, well
just sort of human reflection.
And what can you learn about the
future from human reflection.
And I've really come to see that I don't
think you can predict the climate 100
years from now by human reflection.
But I think you can get people
to think about their future.
And think about choices.
And so I'm curious just to come
back for a minute to climate change,
how has the reaction been
to this tent and how do you
feel you're doing in
getting people to think
about the future and their own futures
with respect to the climate also?
JAMES LEONARD: Well just two
days ago we were exhibiting
the piece in the south end of Boston.
And I was just finishing up a
reading and I overheard somebody
outside who was--
We have a little sign
that sits out in front
of the piece that lets people know sort
of the general house rules, you know.
Sort of, please be
respectful if we're engaged.
And this is what we're doing.
And this is what the piece is called.
So it sort of helps put
people in the right state,
and have some instruction
for how to approach it.
And there was somebody
who just sort of out loud
said, why would I talk to a
diviner about climate change?
And then somebody else said, well why
don't you go ask him and find out.
PROFESSOR: All right that's a
perfect way to put the question.
JAMES LEONARD: The short of it is,
this gentleman walked away not fully
convinced that tarot
works, doesn't work.
But instead that it made him look
at everything that he has already
taken in himself about climate change.
Some of the grim prophecies, some of the
hopeful stuff, some of the stuff that
says don't look at it ignore it.
And juggle it just differently
in his head for the afternoon.
And it got him thinking about it.
And he even remarked that,
sort of, as he left that while
that this is a great tool.
Whether he's going to use tarot or not.
But like just even this way of looking
at this problem, to start digesting it.
Because I think that's one
of the things that I find why
I want to make art about the problem.
Is it's so huge.
It's so overwhelming.
I don't know--
I don't even know about my fellow man.
Just for myself, how do I bite this off?
PROFESSOR: I know people who
will be part of the course later,
who do the climate change
simulations and who do climate policy
research and all of this.
And they also feel overwhelmed.
And I actually think
that what you're doing
is a very important complement to making
people sort of take the perspective.
And look at the context of all of
the different kinds of predictions
about climate.
Most of which are not good
if we don't do anything.
But that giving them a sense
that there are choices,
and that they can think
about the choices.
And maybe they can even learn
something about the choices
from these somewhat time
tested or ancient techniques.
You know, from talking to a lot
of people about climate change,
have you gotten a sense of
whether people respond better
to maybe a positive message
or a negative message?
And how are you thinking more
personally about it makes a difference?
JAMES LEONARD: I think it's actually the
fact that divination is a personalized
story.
Since you are the querent and you are
starting the story off with a question.
There's an instant level
of investment there.
And it's tailored to you.
And I think that engages
people differently.
That personalize it.
And sometimes people are actually
just even looking for affirmation.
But they don't want just
a pat on the shoulder.
They want some sort of external medium.
And this comes around to
one more third major benefit
that I've experienced, myself.
PROFESSOR: Benefit of divination.
JAMES LEONARD: Divination
as a cultural practice,
whether it's connected to a
spiritual practice or not.
Is how it helps us in a
non-pharmaceutical way
deal with chronic anxiety.
Like chronic reality based anxiety.
And there are times where I find
myself saying loss is going to happen,
but it doesn't need to be absolute loss.
That even in and of itself
helps people make some sense.
PROFESSOR: Cause people
think about what that means.
JAMES LEONARD: And it helps sort
of either step down expectations
or get people more on a realistic plane.
That, OK, it can't be
business as usual anymore.
But where do we go?
PROFESSOR: It's been
absolutely fantastic.
And you've opened the
eyes of a scientist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]